President Trump makes a very big
announcement about the deferred action
for childhood arrivals program Hillary
Clinton won't leave and the biggest news
of the day
a failed person who failed at everything
is coming back for more and no I'm not
talking about Hillary Clinton I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
okay now that tease was too good so I'm
just gonna fulfill it right off the bat
later in the show I'm gonna rip JJ
Abrams up and down because apparently
he's coming back for a Star Wars Episode
nine it will be called The Death Star
reincarnation everyone is very excited
about it by which I mean no one is
excited about it
best best joke that I saw today was it
will be called Star Wars Episode nine
Revenge of the lens flare which will be
very amusing but there is actual
balloons to get too many pieces of
actual news that's when we will discuss
all of those pieces of actual news one
by one in their entirety but first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at zip recruiter so are you hiring
would you like to hire people better
than I have you need to use zip
recruiter okay that's the way that you
get the best employees you can post your
job to a hundred-plus job sites with
just one click then they're powerful
technology efficiently matches the right
people to your job better than anyone
else and that is why zip recruiter is
different it doesn't depend on
candidates finding you it finds them for
you in fact 80% of employers who post a
job on zip recruiter get a quality
candidate through the site within one
day okay find out now why zip recruiter
is used by businesses of all sizes we
use it here at Daily wire as well go to
zip recruiter for free and you can try
it out just go to zip recruiter comm
slash daily wired that zip recruiter
dot-com slash daily wire again one more
time
zip recruiter com slash daily where you
can try it out for free list a job for
free and you will start getting
responses pretty much immediately I mean
it's a huge crowd of people who are
gonna be looking for a job and you are
going to be giving it to them and
getting the best possible employees so
go and check out zip recruiter comm
slash daily Wire okay so the big news
that was just announced this morning was
President Trump in his spin to the left
has decided that it is no longer
important that border wall funding be
tied to the to the implementation of
President Obama's executive amnesty now
I'm old enough to remember when every
single rally was filled with two
specific chants really three right was
lock her up
regard to Hillary Clinton she has not
been locked up then there was drain to
swamp
drain to swamp the swamp has not been
drained and finally there was bill go
wall bill the wall and now let's build
the deck up make Jeb Bush great again
okay so as I said a couple of days ago
the fact is that daca President Obama's
executive amnesty as imposed by a
legislature is basically the DREAM Act
that Jeb Bush was pushing for four years
and Donald Trump opposed for years well
now it is being announced that President
Trump the initial idea was that Trump
was going to trade legalization of the
so-called dreamers for the wall right
the President Obama's executive amnesty
for those who don't remember it said
that everybody who's between the ages of
16 and 31 had been in the country since
2007 and come over as a child and didn't
have a criminal record those people
could all stay indefinitely they would
never be deported they would have
basically work permits that's what they
akka was and then Trump came along and
he said we can't do this you know that
from the executive branch let's do it
instead from the legislature which is
not what he had promised Ann Coulter
hardest hit finally Trump says the
Legislature should do it but the idea
was okay his big deal is gonna be his
clever clever deal you know the art of
the deal the magical art of the deal the
magma magma got 3d underwater chess was
going to be that he was going to trade
legalization of these dreamers who had
already essentially been legalized for
toois okay today the hill quote white
house legislative affairs director Mark
Shore told reporters on Tuesday
President Trump would not demand that
border wall funding is tied to a
legislative replacement for the deferred
action for childhood arrivals program
short said were interested in getting
border security and the president has
made the commitment to the American
people that a barrier is important to
that security whether or not that is
part of a Jaca equation or another
legislative vehicle I don't want to bind
us into a construct that would make the
conclusion on daca impossible in other
words Trump wants daca okay it wasn't a
trade it wasn't too clever 3d underwater
upside down Jedi Hungry Hungry Hippos
okay all of this was just he wanted to
make daca great again okay Mecca he
wanted to make deca great again so it
just if you were a Trump supporter who
thinks that he desperately wants the
wall I do have to ask you at this point
are you certain do you think it's going
to happen any time in the near future
because I promise you the Democrats
don't
to do that the Democrats are perfectly
happy his new friends the Democrats
they're perfectly happy to sit on the
sidelines and sink Dacca right they're
happy to sink President Obama's
executive amnesty they don't care
because what they want to say is they
want to say listen we wouldn't trade
anything for that we shouldn't have to
have a wall we should have to have
anything it's such a high priority that
we shouldn't have to give away one dime
we shouldn't have to do anything Trump
wants because he says he cares about the
dreamers we say we care about the
dreamers No Deal
and Trump instead of pushing back on
that and saying listen I'm happy to make
room for the so-called dreamers but we
have to secure the southern border
instead of pushing back he's basically
going okay sounds great why well it has
something to do with the fact that the
President of the United States really
likes the media coverage he has been
receiving over the past week in the last
week we have seen piece after piece one
from the New York Times Trump the
independent president this man is
independent look at him how independent
he is whoa and Trump really likes that
stuff cuz it makes him feel powerful and
strong okay I'm happy to attribute all
of this to strategery but I need to see
these 40 jury and then Trump's guy says
the president is not backing off a
border wall no no the president is
committed to sticking by the commitment
that a physical structure is needed
whether that is part of a daca package
or another package I'm gonna prejudge
that today but he's gonna get that wall
bill mmhmm yeah sure okay
as he on culture puts it we are now
eight months in zero miles of the wall
have been built oh happy happy day okay
so with all of that said this does bring
up a question and that question is how
long is Trump's swivel to the center
going to last how long is it going to
last and why is it a problem so a lot of
people have been saying Trump is an
independent president it's something new
we've never seen this before this is
incorrect if you just want to talk about
a president who broke with his party on
a routine basis we have had many
presidents who have broken with their
parties on a routine basis Bill Clinton
did it with Republicans Richard Nixon
did it with Republicans Dwight
Eisenhower actually did it with
Republicans it's pretty routine actually
for Republican presidents to move
against their own party what is not
routine and where there is a difference
is that Republican base is willing the
Republican base is willing to go along
with Trump on all of this the Republican
base is willing to follow Trump on all
of this right they're willing to say
okay well we used to care about the wall
we
to chant build the wall wheeze to chant
lock her up we used to chant drain the
swamp but as long as Trump wants it we
are happy to give it to him we are so
happy to give it to him and this does
give Trump the capacity to move to the
left on a permanent basis if he wishes
to but there is one thing that is going
to stop him from moving in any real
significant way to the left on a
long-term basis well it's really two
things one is his own tendencies to to
need your backlash and the other is
Democrats hate the guy okay they're
unifying factors they must stop him from
doing things if Democrats are animated
by opposition to Trump that means the
only way Trump can work with them is
complete surrender and that's what we've
seen over the last week Trump so
desperately wants the good headline he
so desperately wants to quote unquote
get something done that he's willing to
work with Democrats again if you're a
Republican if you're a conservative if
you're a trump ster who doesn't like the
establishment you need to ask yourself
why don't I like the establishment if
you don't like the establishment because
the establishment was making deals with
Democrats you don't get to complain now
when Trump when the establishment tries
to prevent Trump from making deals with
Democrats okay this is nonsensical but
again the thing for Trump is that Trump
thrives on opposition and this herein
lies the problem for conservatives
because the Conservatives try to stand
between Trump and his goal working with
Democrats guess who's going to become
the target it's going to be conservative
so to point out how opposition minds at
Trump is yesterday was 9/11 and Trump
gave what I thought was quite a good
speech on the 9/11 anniversary and
here's what he had to say about about
terrorists American forces are
relentlessly pursuing and destroying the
enemies all civilized people ensuring
and these are horrible horrible enemies
enemies like we've never seen before but
we're ensuring that they never again
have a safe haven to launch attacks
against our country we are making plain
to these savage killers that there is no
dark corner beyond our reach no
sanctuary beyond our grasp and nowhere
to hide anywhere on this very large
okay this is all great stuff I do like
when he describes the earth is very
large that is amusing to me but the
point is is not what he says here the
point is what he says next ok Trump
always has to operate in an oppositional
universe so Trump actually said he
started ripping his own advisors in the
middle of the 911 speech basically
here's what Trump had to say the way
President Trump talked today about the
enemy was very important to me so
important to me and so refreshing to me
that I sort of knuckled mine into the
Rope line so I could thank him for
simply saying that our loved ones were
murdered that day that is the first time
I heard a president since 9/11 used the
term murder and I felt it was really
important to say to thank him for that
and he actually said something
interesting to me he said my people
didn't want me to use that word yes
Deborah Berlin
who lost her brother on 9/11 and when
Trump says things like my advisers
didn't want me to say murder the point
here is is not really a profound one it
is just that Trump operates in an
oppositional universe and that's what
made him so popular in 2016 because
everyone hated Hillary Clinton will get
to Hillary Clinton in a little while her
new book what happened is out today and
the answer is actually the bottom of the
book right it says what happened Hillary
Clinton okay that's exactly what
happened okay that is the thing that
happened Hillary Clinton was a garbage
candidate who lost because she was a
garbage candidate I think it's worth
noting the President Trump won fewer
votes in Wisconsin than Mitt Romney did
in 2012 and he won the state he wants
than George W Bush did in Pennsylvania
Wisconsin and Michigan in 2004 right
Bush lost those states in 2004 Trump won
them
that means Hillary was a garbage
candidate but what Trump did better than
anyone else is he's a very oppositional
guy and so his opposition to Hillary
Clinton resulted in a win for people who
opposed Hillary Clinton well Trump
operates the same way on everything so
when it talks about his advisors his
advisors didn't want him to say murdered
and so he said murdered a good way of
getting Trump to do what you want is by
actually opposing what you want him to
do right if you actually oppose him then
he pushes then it's use reverse
psychology basically you say that you
oppose all these things and then Trump
pushes back against you because Trump is
opposite
you know in nature that's not a good
thing for Republicans and conservatives
who are looking at what he's doing right
now and saying this is not good that
you're making deals with Democrats it's
also not good for Democrats long term
though because the fact is that
Democrats are also animated by this
opposition the idea that he's gonna have
some sort of long lasting deal with
Democrats is not true because again he
is an oppositional creature the
Democrats oppose him in the end because
they hate him and they want him out and
that means that they will oppose him on
key issues and then he'll be forced back
into opposition so I don't think this is
going to last for any significant amount
of time here's an example of this so in
the aftermath of hurricane Harvey and a
hurricane Irma the media have decided
that it is vitally important to point
out that they are opposed to Trump now
this should be a unifying moment right
Trump's actually done a pretty good job
handling hurricane Harvey and hurricane
Irma but the media are so opposed to
Trump that they cannot even give him
credit for that
hey Democrats are so opposed to Trump
that they have to they have to rip him
up and down that's why I don't think
this alliance is gonna last very long I
think Trump will try to make it last but
I don't think it's gonna last very long
unless Trump is so driven by the
headline that he decides to surrender
across the board the media for example
Jim Acosta yesterday at the White House
he's asking questions about climate
change and here's what he has to here's
what he has to say he finds an excuse to
rip from for what has been a pretty good
disaster response this administration
saw a connection between climate change
and homeland security and that the
frequency and intensity of powerful
storms like Harvey and Irma could pose a
problem for future administrations you
can
of FEMA budgets that can't keep up with
the demands you have powerful storms
hitting the country is that something
that you think this administration
should take a look at we know the
president pulled out of the Paris
climate Accord are these storms giving
this administration some pause when it
comes to the issue of climate change in
homeland security these are the sorts of
questions that they ask in the middle of
a hurricane is why is Trump so anti
climate change why doesn't he just get
it why doesn't he just follow the
Democratic consensus and do something
about climate change right Joy Behar
does the same thing on the view
Democrats are animated by their own
animus they are animated by their own
hatred for Trump and this is what's
gonna prevent Trump from making a deal
with them in any long-term way hers Joy
Behar who is sort of the it of the
Democratic Party the heat is creating
warm waters in the oceans in the Gulf
wherever and that is contributing to the
intensity of storms like Burma why this
is the worst storm we've ever seen etc
has to do with climate change and people
who deny that they should start naming
all of these next hurricanes after
hurricane Limbaugh hurricane
[Applause]
it's very important that Joy Behar
lecture us on science I mean clearly
clearly she has in many ways conquered
science and and and somehow made it on
TV in any case this demonstrates the
sort of hatred that she has by the way
the note at National Oceanic Atmospheric
and in atmospheric Institute Association
that the government agency they've said
that it's you can't link any specific
hurricane to climate change specifically
in fact we had a very quiet period
before this year in terms of hurricanes
the point here again is that the
Democrats hate Trump so much they're not
going to make deals with him they're
just not gonna make deals with him and
Trump will react to that by not wanting
to make deals with them so I think he's
gonna ping-pong back and forth I think
that's what's gonna happen his
administration is basically gonna be
Trump reacting to whoever hit him last
Democrats right now are being very nice
to him there'll come a time when they're
not so nice to him and when that happens
he will ping-pong back to the Republican
side of the aisle then Republicans won't
be able to get anything done and then he
will ping-pong right back to the
Democrats he is not forming a ruling
coalition here okay he's not forming a
new philosophy and a new ideology anyone
who thinks he is should watch the last
six months where he seems to be sort of
picking and choosing from the tree of
issues varying wildly across what he
says and to whom he says it so I would
not I would not really put a lot of
stock in the idea that Trump is making
some sort of permanent change in terms
of his political orientation that looks
like a third way because isn't a
Clintonian third way or neck Sounion
third way Trump is a man of instinct and
he operates off that instinct which is
good news on the one hand for
conservatives because it means that he's
likely to bounce away from Democrats at
some point in the future but it's bad
news for conservatives right now because
it means that he's bouncing off
Republicans right now to work with the
Democrats okay I want to talk about
Hillary Clinton and her giant fail of a
2016 campaign she just will not let it
go but first I want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at MVM t watches okay
it's movement watches and they were
founded on the belief that awesome style
should not break the bank so I love my
MV MT watch it is this watch it was not
an expensive watch it is it is a very
nice watch it's incredibly durable I
wear it every day it is excellent you
can see me wearing it on my
congressional testimony I really love my
MV MC watch you have tons of different
styles all of them are clean
all of them are simple and they all look
very classy there's such great watches
actually that went on my own
and bought my wife a watch for her
birthday and she really loves it she's a
doctor she works with it and she gets
all sorts of compliments the hospital on
it all of the time it's really a
terrific watch movement watches start at
ninety five bucks at a department store
you're looking to four hundred five
hundred dollar watch they figured out
that by selling online they can cut out
the retail middleman classic design
quality construction style minimalism
over a million watches sold in over 160
160 countries right now if you go to MVM
t.com slash shapiro again that's MBM
t-dot-com slash capiro you get 15% off
today with free shipping and free
returns again clean design inexpensive
prices MVM t.com slash ship here you get
15% off today which is awesome since the
watches aren't expensive to begin with
so you get yourself a really nice watch
that's gonna last the test of time so
it's pretty great okay so you can see
the you know that I think what's the
first step toward pushing Trump back
toward Republican and conservative
positions the first step is gonna be
triumphalism in the same way that Trump
reacts to people who are staffed around
him if they get too much publicity gets
mad at them I think that you're going to
see him start to do this with Democrats
too so representative John Yarmuth his
democrat he's out there cheering Schumer
and Pelosi and basically saying that
Trump is a sucker the more the democrats
Shortell over Trump being a sucker the
more he is likely to bounce back toward
being a Republican again Trump is an
oppositional figure he bounces off of
things okay he's not he's not silly
putty he doesn't stick to a particular
position
he's a rubber ball he just bounces off
of whatever provides him pressure so
here's Congressman John Yarmuth from
third District in Kentucky there there's
no question whatsoever in your mind that
Chuck and Nancy won that negotiation
correct Oh totally want it totally
wanted and believe me they they on
Friday morning or Thursday more it was
Thursday morning I guess they they
looked like victorious warriors when
when they appeared before our caucus and
what did they tell you well they both
just really relished recounting the the
scene in the in the Oval Office okay so
he went on to explain that they said
basically today they screwed Trump the
day they won the debate
the more Trump ears that sort of stuff
the more he's likely to react badly to
Democrats but Democrats have to say it
right if he listens to me he's gonna
react badly to me
hey Trump is like my three-year-old in
this way okay you react bad or really is
more like my one and a half year old who
screams very loudly and then if say no
he screams even louder
okay that's sort of what Trump does so
if I say Trump you got screwed by
Schumer and Pelosi Trump reacts that by
saying that I'm the mean one and
therefore he's fine with Schumer Pelosi
if Schumer and Pelosi make the big
mistake of saying that they're the ones
who screwed Trump over then Trump is
going to react badly to them so we're so
you know we'll see how all of this plays
out but before everybody panics and says
the Trump is permanently in the
Democratic camp I just want to point
that out okay
other things that are in the news today
Hillary Clinton is making her rounds on
her book tour
what happened Hillary Clinton is out
today she still cannot get over her loss
because the loss was a referendum on her
personally the loss was a referendum on
Hillary Clinton personally no one liked
Hillary Clinton I got the election wrong
in terms of the result but I did get
this right I said throughout the
election that this election was not
gonna be a referendum on Trump it was
gonna be a referendum on Hillary Clinton
that Trump was stuck between 40 and 43
percent and Hillary was bouncing around
between 39 and 50 because people
couldn't decide whether they hated her
or whether they were quasi lukewarm on
her and in the end it turns out that
they hated her well Hillary cannot
accept that answer and so she continues
to trot out various explanations for why
she lost so today she did an interview
with USA Today and she said there was a
communication and there certainly was an
understanding of some sort between the
Russians and the Trump campaign she says
there's no doubt in my mind Putin wanted
me to lose and wanted Trump to win and
there's no doubt in my mind they're a
tangle of financial relationships
between Trump and his operation with
Russian money and there's no doubt in my
mind that Trump campaign and other
associates have worked really hard to
hide their connections with the Russians
okay again does she have any evidence of
any of this no this is all a conspiracy
theory until she can provide evidence of
any of this but she says I'm convinced
of it she says I'm happened to believe
in the rule of law and believe in
evidence so I'm not gonna go off and
make all kinds of outrageous claims she
just did one second to go righteous but
if you look at what we've learned since
the election it's pretty troubling and
then she talked about other people to
blame she blamed James Comey she said it
was commies fault that she lost she says
the Comey shivved her she says his
unusual announcement eleven days before
the election revealing her new trove of
emails
ended up screwing her in the three Upper
Midwest states should my first instinct
was that my campaign should hit back
hard and explain to the public that
Comey had badly overstepped his bounds
my team raised concerns with that kind
of confrontational approach in the end
we decided it would be better to let it
go and try to move on looking back that
was a mistake again Hillary blaming her
aides not blaming herself this is the
problem for Hillary Clinton it's the
problem for the Democratic Party
they cannot look internally and say to
themselves what did we do to alienate
all these people so instead what they're
doing is they're doing more of the same
so the big news for Democrats today in
the last few days has been their
continuous and constant focus on
Medicare for all this is their new pitch
right it's Bernie Sanders his old pitch
this medicare-for-all pitch this idea
that we are going to supplement
Obamacare with a scheme whereby everyone
is covered by Medicare because Medicare
is gray they're only a few problems with
this one there's very little evidence
that shows that Medicare has actually
improved health outcomes for people the
reason for that is because most doctors
are now rejecting new Medicare patients
the reimbursement rates are not high
enough for doctors to take new Medicare
patients also
Medicare is already 58 trillion dollars
in unfunded liabilities in debt 58
trillion if you're talking about
expanding Medicare for all making you
know me eligible for Medicare not based
on age not based on health not based on
income then what you're really talking
about is adding 14 trillion dollars to
the national debt in the next ten years
alone which means that will end up being
double or triple that over the next 20
because that's how every government oh
every government program always works
but now this has been embraced right
across the board because Democrats can't
accept the reason they lost is not
because they didn't offer people enough
free stuff
Hillary offered lots of free stuff the
reason they lost is not because they
didn't run Bernie Sanders okay Bernie
Sanders offer people a lot of free stuff
the reason they lost is because they
have contempt for the American people
Democrats have contempt for the American
people particularly white people living
in Midwestern states they think these
people are rubes they think these people
are fools and they think these people
ought to be on the losing end of
American politics that's why they lost
in 2016 they were in the most corrupt
harridan in American history and she
lost and she lost because she called
half the country deplorable and then
their surprise that happened and they
double down on all of these things
they're still calling Trump supporters
deplorable they're still suggesting that
Trump supporters our group of people are
you
personally white supremacists hey Tana
he see coats as a piece in the Atlantic
in which he discusses Trump's election
what does he attribute Trump's election
to he says that Trump's election was not
attributable to Hillary Clinton it was
instead attributable to racism that's
right it wasn't it was all about Trump's
racism Isabelle has signaling to his
white base that he was going to wipe
away the achievements of Obama right now
I said during the election cycle that I
thought the Trump did not do enough to
distinguish himself from the alt-right
that he was sort of covertly and in some
ways overtly pandering to the all
Rekha's he thought they were an
important part of his base but he was
not doing that in opposition to Obama he
was doing that in opposition to the
intersectional laughs of which tonica's
he coaches apart the people who say that
identity is inextricably intertwined
with politics that white people are part
of a white privilege society keeping
black people and Hispanic people down
that's what people were reacting to not
Obama Obama remains the most popular
politician in America Michelle Obama is
right now leading primary polls among
Democrats so the idea that you know that
it's it's really about backlash to Obama
that's what all this was that's not true
it's backlash to intersectionality but
Democrats have to find something other
than themselves to blame because if they
looked in the mirror then they would
actually have to examine what they've
done wrong here and they've done some
things pretty wrong including insulting
the American people on a regular basis
okay so before I go any further and I
have some pretty amazing stuff I like
and stuff I hate today first I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
Lending Tree so right now you're looking
for a mortgage you want to buy a house
but you don't know where to get one you
just go to your friend your friend says
oh you know where I got my mortgage at
blank right well the fact is that blank
is not going to give you as good a
mortgage lending tree lending tree their
customers on average save $20,000 over
the life of their loan and go to Lending
Tree put in all the information about
the property it takes in like three
minutes and then you'll start getting
competitive bids right in front of you
explaining what sort of mortgages are
available it's like shopping for flights
online except you're shopping for the
best mortgage rates available if you're
not sure you have the best deal you
should go to Lending Tree calm /ban
that's Lending Tree calm / bend and
check it out right now this is not
something you wanna mess around with I
mean
mortgages are an enormous amount of
money and it doesn't matter you right
now that it's twenty thousand dollars
more or less on the mortgage it'll
matter in terms of what you're paying on
a monthly basis particularly over the
life of the loan
right now there's a by the way there's a
good chance that your bank is already on
lending trees network of over 400
lenders why not compare and make sure
that you're getting the best deal right
now Lending Tree calm / Ben go over and
try it out today Lending Tree LLC n MLS
number 11:36 Terms & Conditions do apply
make sure you're getting the best
mortgage deal and again use that slash
Ben so they know that we sent you okay
so because the Democrats can't accept
that they lost they continue to trot out
Hillary Clinton is some sort of tragic
figure and some of its really funny so
according to USA Today
there are poignant moments in her book
particularly as she describes trying to
get through the first days and weeks
after the election the suit she'd chosen
to wear for her victory speech white the
color of the suffragettes stayed in the
garment bag he remembered when she wore
the white suit at the convention for the
concession speech the next morning show
her gray and purple suit she plans
wearing her first trip to Washington as
president-elect purple the color
combination of red and blue was designed
as a subtle tip to bipartisanship okay I
still do get a kick out of the fact that
she's not the president you know
whatever I think of Trump and and how he
was behaving lately and how he is
legislating I am very happy she's not
president she's on inauguration day
watching a rival she had warned was a
threat to the nation being sworn in to
the job she assumed would be hers she
focused as she walked down the west
front of the Capitol I'm breathing in
out scream later she told herself I'm
sure she did and I'm sure she hurled a
few lamps and such so I'm just amazing
she says what makes me such a lightning
rod for fury I'm really asking I'm at a
loss well that you're super corrupt and
that you are super rehearsed and that
you are incredibly partisan and that you
think half the country is filled with
terrible people that I think is probably
the problem for Hillary Clinton and when
she's speaking with Democrats she
basically admits as much so she was on
the the pod save America podcast earlier
today and here is what she said okay she
was asked about Putin and the
association with Trump apparently in the
book she says quote Trump doesn't just
like Putin he wants to be like Putin put
down two sensors repress minorities he
dreams of Moscow on the Potomac and she
writes this in her book Moscow on the
Potomac
that's what Trump is dreaming up which
is a wild exaggeration okay everyone
keeps saying Trump is a fascist Trump
hasn't gotten anything done or
imprisoned anyone legitimately the
biggest problem with Trump right now is
that nothing
happening and then he's caving to
Democrats so it's hard to claim that
he's a fascist when at the same time
he's cutting deals with Chuck Schumer
and Nancy Pelosi but here's what Clinton
said she said yes I'm really happy to
say that to the three of you because you
have influence in you have reach look I
wrote this book to try and come to grips
with what happened but also to sound the
alarm about what I think could still and
may well happen I think Trump left to
his own devices unchecked would become
even more authoritarian than he has
tried to be also remember the right-wing
aided and funded by Mercer's Koch
brothers etc is very serious about
calling and constitutional convention
okay the Koch brothers by the way our
libertarians they need thirty four
states last I checked there were 28 or
29 this would be the convention of
states pushed by people like Mark Levin
to check the power of the federal
government but she doesn't understand
that the convention of states has
nothing to do with Trump the convention
of states was moving long before Trump
there's a lot of people who support a
convention of states like me who are not
advocates for the president particularly
when he does things that are wrong she
says part of their German during is to
control state legislatures elect
Republican governors call a
constitutional convention if you get
really deep into what they are
advocating limits on the First Amendment
no limits on the Second Amendment limits
on criminal justice I mean there's a
very insidious right-wing agenda limits
on the First Amendment please talk about
limiting the First Amendment it's the
Democratic Party Hillary Clinton who has
talked about things like hate crimes
laws hate speech laws things like let's
make sure that if you are in LLC you
can't spend money on politics she says
when I say that he doesn't just like
Putin he wants to be like Putin I'm not
saying he's gonna start killing
journalists but I am saying he likes the
idea of unaccountable unchecked power
okay Hillary Clinton saying this people
who like the idea of unaccountable
unchecked power
yeah Hillary we all know why you lost
and this again is why everyone thinks
that 2020 is gonna be a referendum on
Trump
we'll find out it depends on who they
nominate everyone talks about Trump
being low in the opinion polls bottom
line is really really depends on who the
Democrats nominating if they think that
they can run the same campaign they ran
in 2016 and just add single-payer health
care they are desperately mistaken
Democrats have a serious problem in 2020
they don't want to admit it they have a
serious problem they're still using
Obama's coalition and Hillary's strategy
and they're combining it with Bernie's
pie-in-the-sky economics and they have
to because in the primaries if you say
you're not for single-payer then the
Democratic primary vote is too far to
the left
and they'll throw you out but when you
get new in general try to tell people
their health care is gonna be completely
taken away from them and see how that
goes it's the only way to I mean
honestly Democrats are so bad at this
all they truly have to do right now on
health care is just shut up
watch it collapse and blame Trump that's
really all they have to do and instead
what they're doing is they're going out
there with a single-payer plan that
allows them to look like the ones who
want to change health care the rule
about health care is whoever changes it
gets punished politically this is why
Republicans didn't end up changing it
Democrats are trying to change it again
but towards single-payer which
demonstrates by the way but they were
liars all over all along Democrats are
really terrible at this thank God thank
God okay so right now I have a lot of
things I like in things I hate I want to
discuss but for all of that you're going
to have to go over to Daley wire comm
and become a subscriber for $9.99 a
month you can get a subscription over at
Daley wire.com you can get my show live
and get andrew Clavin show wagging yet
Michael Mosley's show live plus we're
doing something very cool Tuesday
September 19th if I survive Berkeley at
5 p.m. Eastern 2 p.m. Pacific subscribe
and we are going to be doing a Facebook
live chat we're gonna be doing a chat
where we where your comments your
questions are answered directly it will
only be available to subscribers we'll
do the first few minutes on Facebook but
then we'll be doing the rest for
subscribers only use the daily wired
chat the comment box that appears on the
side of the podcast on the daily wired
site subscribe ask questions there we
will be reading them live the Q&A will
last for an hour we will answer all of
your questions as they come in so we're
doing that Facebook live with all of
your questions being answered with me
doing more and more things for our
subscribers over at daily wire so
subscribe now for $9.99 a month or if
you do the annual subscription you get
this the very finest and all beverage
where the leftist here's hot or cold mug
I will be using it for protection during
my speech if somebody should throw
something at me I will use this as my
defense mechanism oh just hold it up and
it has its own forcefield it's a very
magical piece of hardware so go and
check that out and get the annual
subscription for $99 a year or if you
just want to listen later please go over
to YouTube please subscribe that really
helps us or go over to iTunes or
SoundCloud subscribe there and leave us
a review on iTunes that always helps
with our ranking we are the largest and
fastest growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
all righty so I wanted to some things
that I like it and some things that I
hate now and this will be a very culture
oriented things I like in things I hate
so things I like I have been watching
lots of children's movies lately because
I have a three and a half year old and
two of the movies that you've been
watching lately one one is Bambi and the
other is Pinocchio so Pinocchio is the
best Disney movie okay it's it's
actually don't think it's particularly
close I think the early Disney movies
are actually much better than the later
Disney movie the animation is actually
better you know leave aside Pixar but
the animation is beautiful it's really
they cuz they did it frame by frame they
have some really cool techniques where
they would actually paint a piece of
glass for the background then they paint
a second piece of glass for perspective
and then they'd shoot through the glass
in order to get that background so I'll
have these moving long tracking shots in
Bambi we have three layers of forest and
they're shooting through three pieces of
glass in order to generate that it's
really a neat technique and and the
animation is beautiful too music is
really great and there's something else
which is that these movies are really
morally sophisticated I mean these
movies have have a lot more darkness to
them than the modern movies and you
think Aladdin is dark Aladdin is nothing
elana Aladdin is cartoonishly dark
Pinocchio is actually dark okay
Pinocchio's a very dark film so here is
some of the preview for Pinocchio the
greatest of all Disney films the master
showman
that's a me and by special permission
management is presenting to you he one
and only he no Kyo when Walt Disney gave
you his first full-length feature Snow
White and the Seven Dwarfs
became a nation's friend you made dopey
the star of his day I hole your favorite
song now Walt Disney brings you his
first and only full-length feature since
Snow White
which one of this grand new group of
characters will be your favorite will it
be mischievous little Pinocchio himself
for a be Geppetto the kindly old wood
carver will it be fluttery frivolous
Clio the goldfish or will it be Roley
fully figuring might be those wily
crooks J Worthington foul fellow and
raggle taggle Gideon or perhaps
Stromboli he is actually so one of the
things I love about Pinocchio is the
entire movie is about why growing up
requires growing a conscience that's
what it's about right the entire film is
about becoming a better person unlike
most of the new Disney films which are
all about self fulfillment all right how
about self fulfillment and nerve hey
Pinocchio is not about any of those
things it's about being worthy of love
right Pinocchio is actually about the
idea that you are worthy of being a real
boy only when you grow a moral soul
right only when you grow a moral
conscience the I always like to contrast
the lyrics from frozen with the lyrics
from Pinocchio the lyrics in Pinocchio
is it says Jiminy Cricket says this race
he's pointed Pinocchio's conscience and
Jiminy Cricket says always let your
conscience be your guide right give a
little whistle and always let your
conscience be your guide walk the
straight and narrow path and if you
start to slide give a little whistle
right and call your conscience that's
the idea again it's a pretty traditional
moral message that's being put forward
in Pinocchio and then you get frozen and
frozen literally says in the middle of
that what's that what's the name of the
big number Malthus in frozen and let it
go one of the actual lyrics in let it go
talks about how morality basically
doesn't matter she says no right no
wrong no rules I'm free that's an actual
line from let it go right that all these
little girls walk around singing it's
the exact opposite of what they say
right now life is about self fulfilment
being yourself creating your own moral
universe that's what's great right
Little Mermaid which i think is one of
the worst Disney films I mean the the
music's great but I think is one of the
worst Disney films and that's because
the morality of Little Mermaid is
basically she disobeys her father she's
a for an hour and a half and then
finally she gets what she wants after
making her father into a small monster
because she saw
the contract to a witch and then she
suddenly gets what she wants
anyway she never learns a lesson there's
no point when she goes oh I guess that
was a really stupid move maybe I should
have listened to dad
there's no point at which at which she
learns anything in the course of Little
Mermaid right Aladdin is a great movie
but it has no moral message and this has
become the thing in in Disney films we
wouldn't want to lecture people on
morality in Finding Nemo it's the father
who has to learn something not the kid
all right it's always that it's always
the adult is now learning something in
all the new Disney films okay that's
because morality in America has changed
and Disney's a great reflection of that
the original Disney films were deeply
moral you watch Pinocchio you watch
Bambi Bambi is all about the idea that
as you grow up you have to start taking
responsibility for others that life is a
bunch of challenges and if you overcome
them you become a stronger person that's
what Bambi is about Pinocchio is super
dark and it demonstrates how we raise
our children differently than we used to
70 years ago like in a real way okay
Pinocchio has in the middle of it
Pinocchio being kidnapped
okay children being turned into donkeys
him being swallowed by a whale right you
think he's drowned okay all of those
things happen in Bambi you have the most
shocking moment in film history right
his mother gets shot off screen right
you know all this happens in children's
films okay these things would be rated R
now right the children's films now are
really innocent and that's because life
and death were a part of normal life for
children a lot more in 1942 than they
were than they are today
but I think that that actually made kids
have more of a moral sense this idea
that life was meaningful because there
was such a thing as death there was such
a thing as morality the morality
Pinocchio's a lot better the morality
today's films also as I say it's a
beautiful movie to watch me that they
will be one of the opening shots there
are a couple of shots in it that are
just incredible there's one tracking
shot where they go all the way through
the town in Pinocchio that's just an
amazing shot again all of this was drawn
frame by frame in that time so every
single frame was being drawn
individually hand-drawn which is it I
mean that's it's an amazing it's
basically like having a flipbook for an
hour-and-a-half pretty incredible
okay so other things that I like so I
have to give it to Jim Carrey I love
this so much Jim Carrey was at New York
Fashion Week as you might imagine I am
NOT a fan of New York Fashion Week and
I'm gonna talk a little bit more about
that in just a second but Jim Carrey for
some reason shows up at New York Fashion
Week and pretend there's some woman who
apparently couldn't afford in a complete
dress so she sort of
residents in in parts of address and she
is interviewing Jim Carrey and Jim
Carrey gives one of the single greatest
interviews I have ever seen in any venue
it's spectacular here we go yes I've
covered a lot of Fashion Week's this is
the first time I've run in to Jim Carrey
wait tell me or is it true you're
wandering the streets you need a date to
the party what's up I'm doing just fine
I just you know there's no meaning to
any of this so I I wanted to find the
most meaningless thing that I could fun
come to and join and they are
celebrating icons inside reading icons
boy that is just the absolute lowest
aiming you know possibility that we can
come up with
it's like icons what do you do believe
in icons I don't believe in
personalities I don't believe that you
exist but there is a wonderful fragrance
in the air you don't believe certain
icons have the power to make change to
think differently to be bold to inspire
others artistry you're one of them on
the good foot you shut it down now yeah
no I I don't believe in icons I don't
believe in personalities I believe that
peace lies beyond personality beyond
invention in disguise beyond the red s
that you wear on your chest that makes
bullets bounce off I believe that it's
deeper than I think that a pretty were a
thing of energy dancing for itself
and I don't care but Jim you got
literally dressed up for the occasion
you look good there is no me there's no
you know we're not here this is a dream
just things happening and there are
clusters of tetrahedrons moving around
together okay it's pretty spectacular
okay first of all I like that he goes
pulled David Hume by the end of this
there's no relationship between cause
and effect are you sure you really exist
can science really determine whether you
are a person but the best part of this
is when he says this is totally
meaningless and I'm here because it's
meaningless pretty spectacular so well
done Jim Carrey dude's a hero not all
heroes wear capes pretty spectacular
okay other things that I like so this
was really funny last night during
Monday Night Football there is a guy a
sideline reporter who I guess is new to
the business and he gives what is
certainly the single best sideline
report in the history of Monday Night
Football
sérgio dip the aptly named Sergio de
pere is what he had to say on the
sidelines Monday Night Football it's a
pleasure to be with you guys here on the
field from up close just watching coach
Ben Joseph from here you watch him now
on the screen this diversity in his
background is helping him a lot tonight
quarterback at Colorado defensive back
in the NFL and here he is
the time of his life in place - that guy
please put him in the in the booth I
mean that guy's amazing here he is
having the time of his life
I don't know what I'm talking about but
words are coming out of my mouth and
they just won't stop
Sergio Dib greatest announcer I have
ever seen
makes Howard Cosell look like nothing
just spectacular ok in other sports
things that I like a lot of things I
like today because people just decided
to go full-on stupid yesterday and you
got to enjoy it or you got a crack ok
this actually was pretty great so slow
and Stevens is the is the name of the
woman who won the US Open and this is a
pretty great exchange it demonstrates
the power of capitalism you've only
don't think about it so here she is
she's asked you know winning the US Open
you're always has dumb questions it
drives my personal trainer nuts whenever
we're watching sports together and we
see these press conferences
he gets so angry at the journalists
because they ask questions like how did
it feel to give up that homerun and say
how do you think it felt I just gave up
a home run I felt great I was totally
for so somebody asks Sloane Stephens how
did it you know does this make you want
to win more majors and her answer is
spectacular no this is kind of fresh but
having done this once does it give you a
hunger to win another slam to do this
again feel this feeling again of course
girl did you see that check that that
lady
like yes man if that doesn't make you
want to play tennis I don't know what
will
man so yes definitely
again capitalism operating even when you
think it isn't so pretty awesome I do
love that that's pretty great okay time
for you know what you know even one more
thing I like because I can't say I fully
like this story
but it is it is funny okay I'm not for
violence
okay violence is not called for if you
have a problem you should call the
police but this is kind of funny okay
there's a bath musician tub piano man he
has spoken out after receiving backlash
on social media and reportedly being
punched in the head Luke Howard began
playing his piano on college green and
Bristol on Saturday September 9th saying
it was his last throw of the dice to win
back his former girlfriend but after
being branded a creep online and
realizing him to play his plan had
failed the 34 year old stopped playing
so this 34 year old guy who couldn't you
know make a decision about his
girlfriend she broke up with him he took
a piano outside her apartment and just
started playing the piano like all
through the night and then at 4 a.m.
people got pissed and he was punched in
the head
according to Bristol Post Luke said he
had been punched in the head at around
4:00 a.m. but added the reason he stops
us he realized he'd spectacular Lee
failed in his original aim the 34 year
old musician rejected suggestions it was
a PR stunt and issued an apology to
those offended by his plan so ok so a
couple of things that I hate about this
number one everybody saying oh he's
stalking her he's stalking her first of
all she thinks he's stalking she can
call the cops okay second of all please
noise pollution people it drives me nuts
when I'm driving around I have I have a
bad habit and that is when I'm driving
around and somebody next to me has their
rap pumped up really loud and it's
bothering me in my own car I rolled down
my windows and I put on the 4th movement
of Beethoven's 9th and I cranked it all
the way up because that's just the kind
of person I am
a complete douchebag so that's it so
it's you know if you're gonna pollute
the noise at 4 a.m. I'm not gonna say
it's OK to punch you in the head I'm
gonna say that somebody should call the
cops on you
and I'm not gonna say that I feel really
terrible for you
I think it's uncivilized but I don't
feel so bad for you ok time for a couple
of things that I Hale do one thing I
hate that I'll do
so here is the thing that I hate JJ
Abrams man what the f dude so he's back
he's now gonna be directing Star Wars
Episode nine aka
Death Star part seven I'm very much
looking forward to a new orb that will
blow up planets but we won't call it the
Death Star I mean can't can't call it
star killer planet instead we'll have to
come I'm hoping that it's blue and then
we can call it the meth star yeah it'll
be like the deaths never be the meth
star it'll be awesome
also JJ Abrams is one the most overrated
directors of my lifetime the idea that
he's a great director is beyond me
the only thing I think he's a better
producer actually than he is a director
I think he's produced some pretty good
films did he directed Cloverfield Lane
he produced it right so 10 Cloverfield
Lane is a good movie because he produced
it not because he directed it lost he
directed the first episode and then he
produced it the first few seasons have
lost are terrific he produced he did not
direct as a director he is highly
derivative everything that he does is a
ripoff of something else the also he
wound my childhood ok episode episode 7
of of Star Wars is The Force awakens
it's one of those movies when you first
watch it you're like all right ok and
then you think about it and then you
think about it and then you think about
it some more and then by the time you're
done thinking about it you're ready to
go burn down JJ Abrams house because he
wrecked my childhood you understand that
when Return of the Jedi ends that Luke
has destroyed the Emperor you understand
that it makes no sense for the dark side
of the force to have crept up again and
be ruling the universe ok you have to
explain what happened with the rebellion
and how they ruled badly if you're going
to explain why there's this new force in
the world also why is it like why did
you turn Luke and Leia who are one of
the best couples in screen history into
a squabbling divorced couple han and
Leia sorry yeah I'm sorry yeah Luke and
Leia that'll be his great revelation in
Star Wars Episode nine he'll wreck the
rest of my childhood not by killing Luke
or after killing han after killing Han
in the most pathetic possible way he
won't just do that he'll wreck my
childhood by announcing that kylo Ren is
actually Luke and Leia's son I'll
completely do he'll go full Game of
Thrones on me but by killing turning Han
into a sad old man who gets murdered by
his pathetic son you know that's going
down first of all this beat that people
use in movies now that drives me
absolutely up a wall is when somebody
will say there's somebody totally even
let's say go stop him
go stop him no don't go stop him you
stupid idiot you're not gonna be able to
stop him everyone knows like okay so
force awakens not good then they're
gonna do episode 8 which the previews do
not look good
and then there's episode 9 which is
gonna be JJ Abrams writing and directing
it and again he's gonna actually create
a new creature a small chat I called
yoga who and and he will also have it
won't be c-3po anymore it'll be c3 geo
everything that he does will be
derivative in some possible way I mean
even bb-8 was bb-8
okay it's just r2d2 with a rounded
bottom okay it's legitimately what bb-8
is JJ Abrams dammit JJ Abrams go away ah
so overrated
Jeremie boring gone King up today Lee
Weyer my business partner he's been
maintaining for years he said I remember
people can vouch for this there was an
argument we had where he made he made
the claim that JJ Abrams was a better
director than Christopher Nolan to which
I say fie fie on you sir sure nonsense
okay time to deconstruct the culture a
little bit so today I want to talk about
Fashion Week so everyone gets very up
for Fashion Week my wife used to watch
the Project Runway and they always talk
about New York Fashion Week
yeah Fashion Week it's the best Fashion
Week okay Fashion Week is where a bunch
of people come up with crappy outfits no
one will ever wear in order to get shock
value so the latest in New York Fashion
Week is they have some idiot designer
has decided that they have to do
something sophisticated so what they
really need to do what's deeply
important is to do a line based on the
work of Dennis of Denis Diderot the
French philosopher
okay the guy who died in 1784 how would
they pay tribute to I'm gonna comb
tennis because I'm American
I guess the Browns Denis they need leave
it all okay their tribute to Denis
Diderot was that they're going to create
dresses covered in vaginas like
literally dress is covered in labia this
was their idea of fashion now I have a
question who is going to wear this is
there anyone like who's gonna buy it is
gonna be like Lena Dunham Lena Dunham is
gonna buy this and just horrify the rest
of us by wearing around the giant vagina
dress I mean I guess these things would
be a best-seller at the Women's March
they're gonna like if you can't tell
where the where the labia are on this
particular thing it's a for some reason
they're there
clinically on her arms which is a weird
place for those to be also it's always
weird to me how they paint the eyes I'm
not sure what happened it looks like
they ran face persons when my daughter's
finger paintings I hear the the the fake
vaginal opening is around her chest
region it's it's what so it used to be I
know that it used to be no when it came
to fashion we actually tree actually
respected designers who created things
that people wanted to wear like look
back at the original Dior okay he was
creating things that women actually
looked good in is there any guy in the
world who looks at this is a god she is
so hot how do you make a beautiful model
look like garbage that's basically what
New York Fashion Week is they've decided
that it's this tendency in Modern Art
that I really hate Stephen Sondheim does
it in theater and I really like early
Sondheim there's this idea that the more
abstruse you get the less people can
understand or they understand what
you're doing the deeper you are the more
you're speaking to something that is
just beyond what the Normie can
understand the normal person can
understand it's so stupid
I have a general rule I'm a relatively
smart fellow if I'm reading a book and
15 pages in I have no idea what you're
saying I'm gonna bet you that it's
probably because you're a crappy writer
not because I'm a okay I figure
that if I went to UCLA in Harvard Law
School and graduated from high school at
16 and have an IQ above 150 I'm figuring
that if that's the case then if I'm
reading your book and I don't understand
it there aren't that many people who can
understand it okay if I look at this
fashion and I don't understand what in
the world you're doing I'm gonna go with
no one understands what in the world
you're doing and this is all just for
shock value because again I don't know
like a file this one under how to make
heterosexual men not attracted to
depictions of pornographic images and
just just amazing please people there's
nothing wrong with quote/unquote
pandering to the common tastes
particularly when there are such things
as an objective standard of beauty I
understand art isn't really art is just
whatever you feel it is art isn't that
okay there are objective standards of
beauty these don't mean it it's garbage
okay let's go back to objective
standards of beauty not everything is
equally beautiful and none of this meets
the standard okay we'll be back here
tomorrow and hopefully president Trump
will have changed his mind on the wall
and I'm sure I'm gonna try and go get a
copy of Hillary's book today
analyze it for you tomorrow hopefully
but we'll have much more in any case I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]